[Music]
what is up everyone and welcome to
another episode of rent cafe episode 29
of Ram cafe how should I say to be the
anime recon style what is the benefit of
the world my name is Anna masse not how
I do it yesterday like this how's it
going on offense rule oh that with style
you gotta do style you're right I didn't
have enough stop welcome everyone twenty
nine yeah it's crazy yeah some long or
that it animates it's at this point more
than a lot of good anime series yeah
it's crazy but yeah welcome guys this
week we'll be talking about anime and
bullying which is a bit of a serious
topic but we're still gonna try to you
know be entertaining while we talk about
it and also deal with some of the more
serious issues surrounding this topic
and the reason we're doing this topic is
we had a few people a few fans on the
channel including Luna in particular say
that they would like this type of topic
addressed a drain cafe because they deal
with that in their own lives and they
think it and we agree of course that
it's an important issue as huge anime
fans as people who in many ways dedicate
our lives to anime in terms of having
channels and you know talking about
anime all the time I feel like it's
appropriate for us to address this issue
kind of what we went through in our
lives what you guys are going through in
your oath in your lives and so on and
yeah in the chat if you had issues an
anime and bullying if you have some
views let us know down you know in the
chat and we'll try to address your
issues questions and concerns today with
me we have breaks from all the anime and
anime reached on and Mac LaMotte should
be joining us a little bit later as well
he's at work but he is gonna be coming
back and as soon as he can he will join
us Briggs what's up what's going on man
I'm pretty good I'm pretty surprised 29
episodes crazy yeah and you've been here
since almost the beginning like probably
the first few weeks right I think I was
on 2nd or 3rd episode it actually forgot
one was the first time I came in do you
remember you were pretty early I'd say
like not not like me Mac Mac and roles
were here on like the first episode
right I think you came with the first
the first yeah the first probably I was
like a non rampa face stream and then
right
after that we did like a rant Kafei
stream and then rose and Mac were first
because there were our first YouTube
friends and then Brinn and then Briggs
and then recon I think oh no and then
Tony in that recon yeah I think I was
the last person when he before we go
yeah yeah yeah very sure he was your
performance than you were then you were
farther than that farther than episode
10 that's for sure
I've no idea 1 episode 10 best episode
who knows she story my lighting is
absolutely horrible I apologize everyone
you know it always just Briggs we've
come to I know I know it is but normally
I'd turn some lights on I didn't even
turn the lights on over there
I'll rush in to get in here I have to
chat up here on a second screen right
beside me so I can look at though which
is sweet thank you two goals and we're
setting it up we got on boo mob came
deep voice kook a imperialist opinions
creep Ellen shout out to creep Ellen
rhyme foo Illya person a person B might
be joining us later and of course Luna
Luna is in the chat so yeah welcome
everyone get comfortable get seated
we're gonna be talking about some
serious stuff and also some fun stuff
before we get into everything anime Rika
I'll give it to you and Rika has some
news that he wants to share with you
guys and by the way make sure to
congratulate both anime recon and Briggs
for reaching that 10k mark 10k
subscribers of course yeah Congrats guys
links to their channel are in the
description and yet it's a big milestone
great work guys great work no your
attack on Titan videos have been going
off like they're really good and you
either just been pumping out you hasn't
really been hitting that YouTube grind
but in together like 12k like two weeks
ago
yeah yeah goes on and I have been really
working our goals in the studies taking
the initiative on these attack on Titan
videos since he finished his school
stuff and even doing a great job and
people really been responding which is
amazing and yeah we really like attacked
an enemy we love with all the whole
world so the fact that we can make
videos about that just like with Code
Geass and people appreciate it
I think it's awesome and yeah so
definitely super grateful likes the
support has been amazing I can't even I
can't even grasp it but yeah amazing
stuff thank you everyone
[Music]
and yes and recon
no yes first of all I want to say thank
you for 10,000 subscribers I don't know
if everyone here is actually supporting
me or subscribe to my channel but for
10,000 are yeah I'm pretty sure you are
I did good anyways I just want to say
thanks for at least having me on ranked
cafe almost every week so I can you know
chat with you guys a great way for you
know to for us to communicate every week
but other than that I'm actually hosting
a top 10 anime competition you most of
you may know that I do reactions and the
top 10 anime and I'm really good at top
tens
so I'm hosting a competition about top
tens if you guys are good at this stuff
and by all means necessary don't
hesitate come and participate in the
competition the winner actually receives
a $30 Amazon gift card where you can buy
whatever you want you can probably buy
up to 3 manga which is just good which
is a good amount that's a lot of manga
but if you guys want to participate if I
don't know how to send the link in the
video because I it's not allowed in the
video but if you go on my channel then
you'll find the 10 K sub the 10 K video
special whatever and you watch and then
over there you'll find out the rules and
everything of what you need to do and
yeah that's mostly about it I also heard
that a Briggs might be participating so
uh right we might wanna go check it out
so the competition con is they're making
the top tens yep
but they're making there only a top 10
and I wanna you think of a style yeah
they're making a video it's just like I
do it's just like I do is just like
anyone does make a video with an anime
list and it has have music and editing
and all this stuff is basically exactly
what I do here he's gonna react to it
and judge what yeah and at the end on
the deadline I'm gonna put them all
together and then react and give my
opinions and everyone's score and then
of course choose the winner so that's
how it works is all it's a lot of fun so
everyone everyone should definitely join
if you're interested yeah absolutely
sounds like a really cool idea recon I
got a gear cube at night actually
up with the plan at first and I was like
hey yeah that's a good idea so I decided
to put it all together into video and
I'm and I'm happy about it yeah and
Sinai blizzard brilliant guy great guy
he was supposed to join us today but he
couldn't cuz I'm some family obligations
that came up last minute but hoping to
have him back next week is a great guy
and definitely looking forward to that
recon recon it does absolutely do great
top 10 / MV videos that I really enjoyed
that I featured multiple times on our
weekly news video because I really like
them a lot he not that much anymore
though which discipline
well recon you know you have so many
romance videos you know switch it up a
bit let me give me some mega top that's
what I'm getting recognized for the most
I'm not gonna lie
yeah do I know I know no but you have to
featured multiple times because you do
do a great job so I absolutely recommend
checking out his top dance he doesn't
like talk about it like some people also
number 10 on he actually makes it a amv
and he finds some really good songs that
I end up like saving and putting in my
like playlists I don't know how he finds
them but I really enjoy them definitely
recommending these videos and I
recommend entering the contest so recog
can give you a platform if you're one of
those creators of top tens but for me I
personally do not like top tens with
voice overs it's just my opinion I don't
like it it just ruins my entire life oh
my god breaks are you with me on this
breaks do you agree no like I know
actually I marry my videos but it's not
my style my style is I'll play my own
planes of stuff but that's fine I like
just like your videos I can be pumped up
for the anime that makes sense
hmm like if I see like you put Kenichi
in one of them best thing ever right
yeah number one for martial arts like
were hungry you were happy I put always
fill that number one Ellis was watching
the montage you got me pumped up and I
want agree watch the show and I saw some
other shows and like he maybe I'll give
it a chance
say Melissa's connection I reckon she
was black god I've watched the black guy
that's really good I haven't watched it
yet but I haven't seen black God but
I've seen the beginning of Black Lagoon
and that
so Black Lagoon is also good with your
two good okay and the modeling in
continuation now the Black Lagoon manga
um yeah so great idea makkal not just
joined us recently guys back from Merck
hey Mac how's it going welcome thank you
it's good work was great I read the last
30 minutes of my work shift I ended up
it ended up being super dead so I just
read the second chapter of Tokyo ghoul
it was amazing
uh yeah good thanks for thanks for
having me do excited to talk about stuff
and the things both of them Sam yes and
we're actually talking about a very
serious topic anime bullying and also
shut up everyone else in the chat
we got Sufi on we got gappy eagle-eye
millennium ring not too fired up was in
there and a few other people caster for
life is saying things like we do best
waifu so that won't just thing
v2 from code yes you didn't watch code
geass no oh macha is there a so what's
up bro so it's been busy working on his
art but i still always enjoy talking to
him on discord of course and if you're
not on our discord already what are you
doing get on there get on there it says
link is in the description so yeah this
whole anime and bullying stuff have any
of you guys experienced bling with
regards to the fact that you're like
anime that you're otaku or anything
along those lines here and in the chat
same question to you guys i only bully
people if they like sword art online I'm
kidding I'm kidding
uh are you freaking kidding me you're
bringing that up again uh hey people
talk trash about it I mean no offense to
anyone but I just come on it's a good
show okay you're cutting out hard for me
brother disrespect idea wrong here II
don't know Mac yeah any serious answer
yeah okay
well I mean yeah I've had people give
the whole I've had people give the whole
spiels you know like you're a grown-ass
man and you watch cartoons sort of thing
and I think most bullying
bullying would whatever you want to call
it or ridicule comes from people not
really knowing what's going on like they
they criticize before they before they
think right like you know it's someone's
first glance they see it's animated they
assume it's a cartoon they assume it's
for kids right you're a grown-ass man or
a grown-ass woman or grown ass whatever
watching cartoons and to them they can't
really like they don't comprehend that
right like it doesn't fit into their
doesn't fit into their mindset so I mean
I think half of I mean my experience
half of the bullying or whatever you
want to call it that comes from liking
anime is usually just people who don't
know what's going on and then there's
people obviously were just messed up and
want to see the world burn that's hold
up their story but yeah that's my
general experience just people not no
one wants up that's not really their
fault right
yeah and that's true I've experienced
that too as the editor became an anime
fan kind of like wearing an anime shirt
or the fact that I'm an animator channel
or whatever people like ma'am you're a
grown man why are you why do you care
about these cartoons and that is a big
thing in terms of the whole cartoon
stigma cartoons are for kids we have
some people in the Chad that had some
stuff said spook a said that in the
seventh grade she was bullied and called
Japanese trash so that's another
interesting concept because the whole
weeaboo thing right so now if you're
like animes some people who don't know
the difference will call your vehicle
right away saying that you're pretending
you can be Japanese because you like
anime stuff or you know enjoy talking
about Japanese culture or something
because you like anime so that's another
reason why people might be bullied
nowadays imperialist opinion said
something interesting he said I haven't
really been bullied but then I also
don't really talk about liking anime in
public right so that's another thing
some people don't feel comfortable
talking about it and it's because
they're afraid they're gonna get some
kind of you know weird reaction
sometimes I think sometimes it's also
just you know I I do I'll do things for
instance like as a hobby that I don't
necessarily go out of my way to tell
people hey I winged surf or I
rollerblade but naked things like that
I'm not saying that watch
anime and rollerblading but- on the same
level rollerblading naked is way more
fun but you get my is my drift you catch
it it's I think some people are
embarrassed by it hekia and like I kind
of get why I kind of kind of don't but I
think it's it's kind of like half and
half sometimes sometimes you just don't
just don't yeah and I don't know where
you are allowed to rollerblade but make
it Mike hey I grew I grew up in the
middle of nowhere you can do whatever
you want there's nobody around it's true
man but you know do you man do you I
don't personally I don't want to see the
anime made for your but I think your
budding although I would be surprised if
it was with the whole ballroom and URI
stuff going on but you know you know to
each his own um Luna says said multiple
times and I've talked to her about this
and this was actually because I've heard
that I decided to do this topic because
she told me multiple times that she
lives in a very small town in a
conservative area and she has been
bullied a lot and called like Satan and
all this kind of stuff for liking anime
because the people that don't understand
and then it's a very closed community
and you know they don't know about anime
so they thing you know they see like
edgy or something anything this is
clearly corrupted and wrong and in a
terrible influence and you know Satan
and all that kind of stuff so she's had
issues with that soul maka asked an
interesting question he's like do people
who like like Marvel and DC like comic
books do they also get hate cuz he says
he's never gotten hey cuz he thinks he's
so cool
but um Marvel is related to anime but
the thing is it's it's before I feel a
lot of people who did like you know
comic books were considered nerds and I
was a way people did pick on him for
that however now with the Marvel and DC
being so popular with the movies right
like that Marvel movies especially the
superhero movies taking off it's been uh
kind of it's become much more mainstream
and accepted you know I like those
movies I like those heroes so why would
not like the comic books so now after
there's less hate for that because a lot
more people under
because when you understand something
that you're not as quick to hate on it
right mom so yeah I think that that's
changed a bit but I think that yeah
before a lot of people were like oh
you're a comic book nerd kind of thing
and hopefully add maybe get to that up
to that point eventually right and
that's I think it's already kind of on
the way there it's obviously really on
there because we weren't talking about
it right now but like it's I think it's
it's getting because it depends on like
what's trending right like superheroes
used to not be cool all of a sudden
movies started getting made they became
popular it's cool to like superheroes
same sort of things kind of happening
with anime like I see not posers I don't
like calling people posers but you see
you see people like a sometimes like I
met a dude once who was wearing a what
was it it was some anime I forget what
it might have been a sword on my shirt I
want to maybe say it was a sort of lunch
'red it just looked cool so we wore it
like I asked him oh cool like do you
like the show and stuff he said he
didn't even know what it was so I mean
that was that you were so sure it is
even know what the [ __ ] the anime is
well nope
I don't even interesting point it's kind
of like that art style is becoming more
accepted so um I feel like that's that's
is a good sign and of course the fact
that you know the Olympic Games and talk
you're gonna have anime characters as
mascots is a big thing the fact that
cowboy bebop is getting on American
live-action series Death Note is getting
our patient goes in the shell got an
adaptation even though we don't
necessarily like those adaptations it
still as a sign that anime is becoming
more mainstream and the anime community
on YouTube has grown a lot like you now
have anime youtubers with over a million
subscribers few years ago that would
have been impossible so I feel like
definitely is getting more mainstream so
it's getting better but for example for
Lunas situation she's in a very small
community only a few hundred people and
then that is gonna be a much different
situation than if you're like in New
York or like a big city right now here's
the question though that people do
generally get treated differently around
the world let's say like in America or
in the UK compared to Japan because in
Japan the anime industry is huge so if
you like go out there and public and
start talking about anime you are more
like
not to get bully because it's very well
known out there people know exactly what
it is and you go to Tokyo Aki borrow you
gonna see anime like everywhere being
advertised on the [ __ ] buildings
shops everywhere when you go to school
you talk about anime you can spread out
information just say what you like about
anime but in the u.s. people they don't
know about it even here in the UK they
don't know about it not many people are
really interested in anime so we start
talking about it they will think that
your weeaboo for myself i have been
bullied for actually wearing an sao
shirt yes that is true i was not by
bacala no not by a coma i was actually
willing for wearing an sao shirt and
people were worse and some people were
telling me like what is that that
cartoon do you like cartoon you're such
a weeaboo and i by a mistake i actually
also told people I was watching
currently I that time I was actually
watching highschool DxD first time ever
and I decided to show them a picture of
why I was watching and I showed him a
picture of Ria's Gremory and they were
disgusted by what they saw so yeah it
was bullied for a while but that then
that was let off but if you genuinely do
want to talk about anime in the US or in
the UK go to like events go to events
like I don't know Comic Cons and all
this stuff over there you can talk talk
to anyone about enemy if you want yeah
except of course if you live like
somewhere in the middle of nowhere like
Mac and you can't make it there then
that's the thing like you live if you
live in a small community close
community especially and this is
bullying in general an issue not just
with anime but it's like if you live if
you're in high school or elementary
school you have to be around people you
don't necessarily like all the time like
you're forced every day to be around
these people become until you become you
know so independent you're out of high
school and then so you have to be with
these people and they'll bully you and
that's that's you know we might have a
for anime am i having for a whole bunch
of different things because kids in
school get like that they get very
cliquey they get very um why does this
focus keep shifting but I'd be like in
color like the colour of my camera keeps
changing but that's that the starving no
yeah but the thing is
then yeah you have to kind of get
through that part because you don't have
a choice you have to in high school
elementary school you have to be there
every day so you have to kind of deal
with it because it's when you can just
kind of like take yourself out of the
situation and but I wish out out to girl
bro in the chat I see her also anime
life says he'll be 20 to me tomorrow how
be early birthday bro and he says that
he calms of a grown man but he's proud
that you can talk about anime when he
wants and he doesn't care what people
say as long as he enjoys it himself and
I've sold I agree with that 100% uh
you're more affected by bullying in
terms of people looking down on you if
you don't have confidence if you're
trying to like please other people the
time if you are had the confidence and
you know this is what I like this is
what I want to do then you won't be
affected by it of course it's different
again like I said if you're in school
and you are you can't get away from
these people once you're out of school
and you can live your own life and if
you have the confidence and you won't
let it bother you that you know that
people are looking down on your stuff
like that Briggs I want to ask you if
you ever got bullied I don't think you
did cuz you're jacked
are you completely cut out man what you
said I said I don't know if you ever got
bullied cuz you're jacked but if you did
um I've definitely been like teased it's
more like I think it's always in good
fun from like family and friends type of
thing and like I it's like I'd go with
it like with like in fun I got in a few
comments I'm sharing like like end up
high school I feel like I just didn't
care at that point I would classify
myself when I was younger as like a
closet anime fan and it wouldn't talk
about it because I was always worried
about what people would thought would
like think but as I got older I became
like a part of who I am like I watched
so much anime buy merchandise have a
youtube channel if your life starts
revolve around it it's didn't feel right
to start had to hide it type of thing
and I just like I had more confidence
when I was like grade 11 grade 12 type
of thing I didn't care I cosplayed as
Goku and I don't know I I think I didn't
care and I'll in a point in my life
where like I feel I had to get a few
comments but it just doesn't bother me
to be honest where did you cosplay as go
quit school in high school I slouch
a lot of people loved it like they
recognized like Dragon Ball Z from their
childhood like more people recognized me
than like my girlfriend with like a
dollar that I remember like what are you
and then like people like yeah I go to
guys that's a great point Briggs that
you know when you eventually when you
get older I find you have more
confidence because you know Connor you
know who you are more you have more
confidence in yourself and then it
doesn't bother you as much but like yeah
when you're at that in a vulnerable
stage in elementary school high school
where you're trying to fit in and make
friends and stuff then it's a very hard
situation when you're being bullied
constantly for something you're
passionate about because you want to fit
in you want to have friends but you also
don't want to give up your passions and
you don't want to hide you know why you
want to do so that is I think a
difficult situation and me personally I
never got bully because of anime because
I wasn't that into anime you know in
elementary school in high school it's
only later that I realized how great
anime was but I when I was younger I
moved around a lot because we were you
know in the former Yugoslavia there was
a civil war so we moved it around there
that we moved to Canada and because I
was the new guy I sometimes got bullied
at least at first for being the new guy
and I find that it's basically with
bullying it's like whatever makes you
different set you apart is what people
pick on because why do bullies bully
it's because they want to act look cool
in front of others so they find
something that makes someone else
different from them and the others so in
order to make them closer to those
others and make them seem cooler in
their eyes they pick on that one
difference that they see in this case um
anime is one example duh but it could be
that you're the new guy it could be that
you know you don't speak English as well
or something like that and then people
pick on you for that so I think that in
terms of like a small town especially
where anime is not well-known and it's
not mainstream yet you can definitely
find see that becoming like a big thing
where it's like oh we don't like anime
we don't know what that is and this
person likes it let's pick on them and
that way we look cooler to each other
by having an enemy that we all you know
fight against you know there's us and
then there's that person the outsider
I definitely agree I agree with them the
outsider that sounds way cooler than it
is the outside always it always just
tends to be the new kid that gets
bullied every time when you come to
school I never thought about it that way
like the difference and like someone
from a point of like insecurity will use
that to like put themself I like put
themselves with everyone else because
you're the odd person out for whatever
trade it is type of thing I never
thought about it from that perspective
make solution usually when you when
you're the new key people tend to test
you out
people like test you out and see how
you're like what what you do and all the
stuff they ask you sort of questions and
all this stuff and if they think that
you're weird that yeah they will start
to pick on you from now on it always
tends to be the new guys would you bet
and it's almost like in some ways like
as the new guy you're not sure how to
react cuz like should I stand up and
you're not getting a fight with these
people - exactly
to prove that I'm not weak or should I
try to like win their friendship I'd be
nice like you don't know right so it is
definitely hard for that person hmm some
people in the Charter say that they like
Ruby even though it's not an anime like
I'm not saying much belly blues people
good I'm not saying you shouldn't bully
Ruby fans but I think I thought Ruby was
cool I haven't finished it obviously
like every other show that I've ever
started ever but from what I saw I was
pretty cool
I don't I I very much enjoyed the first
few oh yeah it's very fast you just
watch it on YouTube in like one sitting
and I'm like did you get a boob mousepad
from the anime north I'm pretty sure you
bought one yes we did yes we're just you
know it's time for us to be bullying
isn't it not only is it you know I have
one I showed it sounds on camera D -
yeah there she is katrell fujio's 3km PS
there was some far more provocative ones
like the booty mousepads no I don't like
booties not for me really I like the
boobie mouse pad not a [ __ ] little
fuzzy
I love booty calls like this is like you
cannot you cannot have anyone at your
house and show this like this is just
gonna like this is too much man there
was some there was some amazed
chopper from one piece but mousepads and
I almost got one
I didn't buy one because I felt like I'd
be at felt like I'd be entering the
poseur the poser realm but actually ran
out of time before I could get a
mousepad so I like didn't get them as
bad I'm kind of bummed about it okay
how about this question let's say if you
have Amazon I was off your best friend
Matt if you need it for like a blogger
if you're getting I'll just get it and
say that I got it at inna my door so I
can have it in my dad on everything yeah
I got got this at Convention not
amazon.com we live on YouTube hey did
you guys have an anime room while you
were still in high school did you like
probably maybe invite your friends over
and for the first time they see your
room and they start thinking you're
weird did you ever have that well let's
say you brakes you have an anime room
you got posters all around you did you
have that in time of high school not at
that time yeah I got a hello look at
what someone up to my room
a female up to my room and with all the
posters and stuff it was really good
tightest view that here very enjoyable
you know it's it was very like childish
you meup anime being childish just like
a lot of things everywhere it's like my
room didn't grow up because like I mean
I'm not in it that often my room you
probably many people have already sent
out posters and [ __ ] about maybe 12
figurines of characters from my favorite
shows and [ __ ] like that but in 13 body
pillows no I'm one I'd love to buy more
action like I could just line them all
up and Bend then jump on top and I was
like to get on the harem King oh that
would be amazing that actually be a
really good skit video no doubt it would
be like to me it would be more amazing
if it was a real harem but I mean
whatever you like whatever you like um
Mac got an interesting body pillow
actually at anime North believe it or
not
who is it I don't know Mac are you going
to be revealing it yourself
reveal it is it REM I'm not saying you
because if you're gonna be really gonna
video we're not gonna say anything
oh I am yeah kind of you guys already
know I have a reason I've shared all
right you guys look out for the Mac
reveal I think the body pillow I he did
buy an actual body pillow I side with my
own eyes
beauty's be prepared it's gonna be in a
lifeless hit - yeah I know what is one
out but anticipation what could it be
when pressures from I mean I'm not
saying it's not REM but it's also not
whole otherwise wolf which was an option
is an option
so you find play if it was that
individual which is the blank like a
blank pillow I'm not sure like a blank
pillow a blue rent a different arms and
all the normal like alright what's a rim
rim I even I forgot to say it but hey
you know but um if you got a whole one
then you know that chibi reviews is
gonna break into your house and try to
murder you and take it for you just
warning but we not so fired up said at
school he goes to the computer room to
watch anime uppers awesome videos and
then people call them a [ __ ] weave
and flick them in the head what not to
don't worry we'll get them bra I'll come
out that with a nice L kamehameha yeah
girl don't worry as the community grows
we're gonna form our own defense squads
all over the world they should popular
lies are we making militias right now we
gotta go because I am absolutely a
called the world's [ __ ] the bridge or
you're going to form a committee for
Public Safety history buffs will know
what I mean well that's a good idea and
aback you should make a body pillow by
yourself Oh buddy pull myself yeah
basically just put like the camera
somewhere and is lying it was largely my
pose or something take a picture send it
to a comfort
and they'll do officially a body pillow
just add about one sided
recon I'm flattered that you find me
that attractive and you think that now I
don't [ __ ] body pillow of me a big
selling I don't but I don't think that's
the direction I want to face I mean
don't you have a bunch of fangirls I'm
pretty sure you do yeah but I mean I I
don't want to be objectified like that
bro I wanted to look at a sloth meat
that you can just objectify he's a
strong independent man who don't need no
fangirls yeah like I want them to love
me for my heart and on my sexy sexy body
to Sexy's to sing evoke a boku no pico
body-pillow no thank you
all right it's been a slice I'm out it's
been I'll see you next week cool yeah
man has a new rule anyone tongue someone
says boku no pico he's out of here he's
not everybody everybody though calls me
Ricardo Pecos ooh yeah yeah Rica no pico
you you can't have you know baku no pico
not mentioned at some point man recon is
here even when he's not here we were
like where's Rica no Pico so there's no
escape hmm best best show the season is
definitely a boku no pico academia
though again that's a different gonna
pick Academy yeah I love another pen
would recommend I'll actually want to
tie into what you guys are saying about
like I completely agree I think all you
guys touched upon it a little bit about
like if people just don't have a good
understanding of what anime is and you
guys are all talking like people seeing
it as cartoons which is true and most
people's only representation is like
Pokemon and stuff like that but also
like the media either like one extreme
or the other because I they all like
media only really cares about views and
stuff like that so either like
children's cartoons or like pedophilia
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and not saying that both
don't exist just like everything in
between exists as well and it's
thousands of series that are amazing
like series that stand like Death Note
fate/stay night fades zero type of thing
like I think this no one would ever make
fun of someone for watching like
Breaking Bad or um Game of Thrones and
that's like theories that like are in
similar tones and maturity of those type
of shows in anime like is people have a
horrible representation of what anime is
and a lot of is because of the media or
their only exposure is like Pokemon yeah
and like that's the one thing that I was
thinking when they said um Cowboy Bebop
would be becoming an American TV series
on the one hand you're thinking of crap
another adaptation but on the other hand
I'm thinking of shows like breaking bad
Game of Thrones house of cards all shows
I really enjoy and I'm thinking like
what if they actually did a good job
with a cowboy bebop show like what if
like that would be amazing if they could
do a show like that that becomes iconic
and they're like and then you know
something magic a show like how about
becoming iconic in the West like Game of
Thrones if you're like oh by the way
this is based on I'm anime yeah like
anything I respect that award-winning
channel like that would mean a lot for
the anime community now yeah believe me
Thrones was an anime how great that
would be oh man do it girl bro no body
pillows I'm not that desperate for money
yet so no body pillows as it right now
yet yeah you were yes yeah oh by the way
on other things that I want to talk
about is do you guys think there's a way
to avoid being bullied for liking anime
um you know any strategies to deal with
bullies if you can't avoid them because
let's say you have to be at school with
them all the time I'm back you can I
mean I'm probably not the best giver of
advice for this cuz I was home-schooled
and literally the middle of nowhere all
through my school so I don't even know
uh I've got some advice if you get
literally get bullied then you got no
choice if it's gonna keep on going
you're gonna have to punch the guy just
you know teacher like I said earlier
it's like you pay anime don't mess with
anime haha just [ __ ] you just give him
like a smack on the face that's all
buddy
I imagine if anime fans became that
militant and it's like I become like
gangs
so like any school it's like yo that's
the you know that's the crazy gang you
know that's the drug dealers and does
the anime gangs like they're the
craziest man you say one thing about
anime they wait for you after school
twelve of them they wait for you with
that [ __ ] they got like nothing look at
the kawaii get a ganked the Broadway the
cousin brings a cue man you're [ __ ]
you don't mess with the anime offense a
little Lin brother I think a fellow say
what
oh no go for it um all the same like
anime recall the same like plunge the
guy in the face even better than that
get involved in school like in high
school a lot like do a lot of sports
work out like I work out a lot and like
you don't you don't need to be actually
strong just have the guns for show right
usually you just say my totally [ __ ]
up I feel like what if he's not afraid
of you if you look tough and if you
double self-conscious confidence too but
like I found a lot of people that got
bullied in my high school or people that
like we're very this kept themselves and
had no involvement in school and didn't
have like a group of friends I feel like
if you become type of person to get
involved and had like a big group of
friends it's like you don't care what
other people think because all you care
about is what your friends like same
type of thing and you have people to
rely on and those type of like tough
situations and then it said a lot of it
comes down to self confidence go ahead
Anna Mac yeah that's true if you have a
lot of like a good circle of friends to
support you then that is of course a
huge benefit but the problem is what if
you're the new guy as we mentioned and
what if you can't find out supportive
circle friends that that's when the
difficulty arises like of course one way
to avoid anime bullying is to hide the 5
year an enemy fan so like imperialist
opinions mentioned in chat he doesn't
really talk about it in public you know
he enjoys it at home or with friends he
knows like it and then he doesn't get
bothered because of that but then some
people really want to actually express
themselves through their love of anime
and then that's where they come into
conflict with people who just want to
bully them so yeah that is it's there's
no
easy solution to this right because
sometimes you know with bullies with
bullying it's a huge issue and you don't
you know sometimes you not you don't
feel safe going to the teacher because
then you might get building more for
being a tattletale sometimes you you can
just hide that you're into it but that
means that yeah sometimes you can hide
your edges on those you can or you don't
want to because you want to beat out to
be a part of your life so it is a
difficult question so yeah and yeah you
can say especially with guys we're like
well not come out bro knock them out but
like there's also girls who get bullied
like Luna where it's like how do you you
know you girls they don't just knock
each other out it doesn't solve the
problems so it is you know it is a
difficult issue but I'm definitely not
open to advice from either any of you
guys or anybody in the chat in terms of
this type of stuff and again it gets a
lot easier once you're out of high
school because again even if you're in
university you choose the classes you
take you don't um you don't have to be
around the same people all the time so
it's much different while you're in
elementary school in high school you
definitely kind of are stuck there with
certain people every day
and that is the most difficult part I
think until you get out of that
environment if you're being bullied yeah
cuz after high school is great because
you only surround yourself with people
that you want to be surrounded with
right and my only advice to like the new
kid type of thing is to get involved
I feel like try to not be that new kid
for like trying to close that gap as
fast as possible like join clubs join
teams try your best to make sure like
it's hard it's very tough situation I
would just recommend getting involved I
like I said before I like a lot of
people that I knew or just like kind of
like L Catholic it like you said before
the person who's different the person
who was the outcast actually trying to
like joining clubs and stuff in teams
getting involved into would definitely
help with that yeah I think it would be
cool actually
you know people are like oh man that
y'all my freedom but in Japan they're
forced in high school to join a club oh
I think that's a good thing yeah and I
think I'll be very cool if you were like
you could choose which club but you had
to join it and join a club because you
would kind of you would be forced to
come up with like a group of friends
that share
similar interest and I thought that
would be a really good way to bond with
people to meet friends and yeah so like
having like that kind of thing that
being part of one club at least or
something like that as part of your
schooling that would be I think a cool
thing my best memories from high school
are teams and clubs yeah cuz you build
that kind of camaraderie right
um 2spooky shout out to him in the chat
he says it's pretty simple you just
scream as loud as you can either a they
get confused and leave or be you go
super saiyan so it's a win-win situation
it's all four thousand I imagine imagine
someone's like hey you loser you like
every scar you would get pretty freaked
out if you're the bully you're like what
the [ __ ] leg on some [ __ ] right now and
shut out the giro the hero he says
hashtag rant gang you guys we're not
forming a militia guys I am but my
bullying was all in the past now I'm
happy I completed high school and I'm
currently in college I'm almost actually
done with college in about a week and
I'm done but it's summer and then I'm
heading off to uni so to be honest I'm
pretty sure many of fans here of Anna
Mack are still in school and all the
stuff if you're experiencing bullying
and trust me that will all change
because as I was like in my in my life
during college for those for the two
years in college I did express myself
that I do like anime and it was it was
amazing like people people didn't mind
that I like anime people actually just
went on I made a lot of friends in
college and I was pretty happy they knew
I was like anime that some of them
actually know that I have a YouTube
channel so they don't mind they watch me
they support me and I was really really
freaking happy and I found a place that
you enjoy a lot that's awesome dude
another thing people are more mature in
sorry I keep on cutting you off at Mac
just no no problem I'll be just robably
delay or something so go ahead if it's
still hard um I don't think people are
more mature afterwards as well high
school looked like a difficult time for
everyone yeah yeah
so the and I think that is an import
point that you raise again after you get
out of high school with it's much easier
and you can kind of determine your life
more and that way you can choose who you
hang out with and all that time so it's
also they feel like I feel like in some
schools now even in high schools I
definitely know at universities but I
should you like anime clubs and stuff in
areas where you know let's say there's a
lot of it's it's a diverse community
like a big city like Toronto or LA or
New York and there's like diverse people
there and diverse interests you will
definitely find an anime club and so
like in some people might be anime fans
that have a great high school experience
but then if you're like in a small town
and nobody knows about anime and they
just look at it with suspicion then
you're like oh man this is um this is an
issue and uh on who actually has an
interesting thing he said what about
when anime fans are themselves the
bullies and he talks about the manga
called Tokyo ghoul being attacked for
not making his main character gay and I
think like you can't say that that's
anime fans like you have crazy people
everywhere in every community and those
are just crazy people they're not like
they're just like looks like a small
segment of crazy people that are just
I don't even though they're anime fans
or they're just specifically fans of
that one anime or manga or whatever but
yeah like that's if you're a fan of a
manga ky4 actual fan like you like his
work and you should respect him for
giving you a role you know all this
stuff why in the world would you be you
know say things to him like kill
yourself and stuff like that's not a
true fan that someone who's just like
very selfish and very ungrateful so I
feel like in that sense yeah you're
gonna find those types of people but
you're gonna find them in every
community not just anime I don't think
the anime community is any more toxic
than any other is just that we have
certain segments of people who are
reasonable and certain who are not right
by the way drop a like if you support
our anime defense force as uh so we're
going to get on you and I do you think
we should start a guild called Edo anime
self-defense force
yeah call it uh guilt cuz it's it just
sounds nerdy doesn't sound dangerous it
sounds better than militia okay I bought
chicken
okay how about military let's create a
military called the anime self-defense
force and just go trash on people who
hate anime and just you know what do you
think we should do them tell them they
smell bad
that'll get I'm sure I think we should
torture them people who have asked about
anime deserve to be tortured in a
torture chamber yeah a few people are
talking in the chat interesting a saying
that like some people are saying that
they actually got people who disliked
anime like their friends or people they
didn't know to like anime after they
expose them to it and that's a very
interesting concept because I know that
personally I was skeptical of anime
until I saw Death Note I was like dude
this is not a children's show this is
amazing like just like someone watching
Game of Thrones or something like this
is this type of quality complexity but
the thing is that yeah it's like depends
how open-minded the people are because
if someone is open-minded enough to
watch Death Note or some other show you
love and ends up liking it then that's
amazing but unfortunately not everyone
is that open-minded it won't actually
give you the opportunity to change their
mind because they're completely
closed-minded completely ignorant and
it's those kinds of people that become
you know the worst type of bully so many
people are doing hashtags right now yes
what they're including yourself what
where you got anime defense words in
capital letters did that post it yeah I
actually decided you know what okay
let's get this trend going hashtag and
my self defense force and channel a
defense force has nothing on the shrimp
aku Alliance so yes I will see Briggs
we'll see we're not against you Briggs
were together mwah yeah you're part of
the district order your property best
more so don't be like a law you can be
on a lower right group in the in the
ship populates the enemy defense force
brick brick Briggs when Bruno or crucial
you know enforcers it's true we are part
of the anime uproar it's like I'm sure
bitey
I'm sort of sad by the way anbu is
saying join our discord to join our
quest for world domination and yes you
can do that link is in the description
you also post the link in the chat and
another thing is like if you're really
finding in my opinion again I'm not a
you know expert on these things I can
just tell you what I kind of think so
don't you know take what I say 100% you
know as law but my thing my thinking is
if you really are surrounded by toxic
bullies that you can't avoid and they're
not open-minded and they don't want to
give you the time of day what you can do
is again keep your love for enemy to
yourself and then find communities
online like this one where you can share
and discuss it and be a part of it and
then when you're out of high school and
you don't have to deal with these same
people order again
then you can kind of seek out people who
share your interest and be and express
it more and you know I feel bad saying
you know don't express yourself in high
school as stuff like that and I think
everyone should if they can but again I
don't want to tell anyone to go and
provoke people who are clearly ignorant
and clearly you know out of their minds
into like hurting them right so you have
to really make the decision if you feel
like it's really toxic and you really
could be harmed by these people if
you're trying to push it on them then
maybe the best strategy would be to kind
of like do it yourself
keep it to yourself have an online
community where you can get the support
and then later when you have more
independence in life to kind of go your
own way but that's just my thinking
again I don't know what you guys think
about that I think that's a good point
like if you're already being bullied I
wouldn't bring up something that's so
what's called not like people like
something like adding me that people
aren't educated in both it's like if
you're already a employed why why would
you give it like give people a reason or
something to bill you for on top of it
if you keep on constantly getting
bullied you don't you don't really
necessarily have to tell the teacher
like teacher these kids these kids are
really bullying me because I like anime
like don't do that don't be a teacher's
pet I mean it will look embarrassing if
you actually tell it tell the extent
right like if you're getting like like
physically bullied I would say go to go
to some
one right yeah it's like verbal teasing
obviously I have one that like takes
things differently like I wouldn't
recommend it personally like going to a
teacher or something like that yeah yeah
I say if you keep on getting bullied
just you keep your distance away from
those bullies don't don't come in
contact with them don't don't make eye
contact you don't have to do anything
anything to do with them just keep your
distance away but if they do like
probably say stuff to you like your
Weibo just just inside you just feel
good about it like yes I'm a weeaboo I
like and just feel good about it I don't
have to get it to you don't let it get
to you just feel good about it like yes
I believe oh I like anime I don't give a
[ __ ] what people say but hmm so feel
good that's all you do self confidence
right yeah just be confident you don't
just don't let things get to you that's
all you need to do it's time and again
it depends because sometimes when we
think of bully we think of a reasonable
person with just being you know teasing
us and then psycho watch the same there
I go okay and I'm like oh yeah I like
that but it could really be like a
really you know violent like ignorant
close-minded person so we have to allow
for those differences as well and kind
of adjust accordingly but yeah if you
find someone's really toxic it's the
best thing is to avoid them as much as
possible and just to kind of then when
you have when you're out of that
situation then to kind of be yourself
there but however be careful obviously
if you're being physically abused during
that and go to someone whether parents
or school authorities or even to cops
like of course don't let someone
physically abuse you and get away
because you never know that stuff could
just get worse and worse these people
are clearly unstable there's something
wrong with them not you so you got a you
might have to like do something about
that
tsukushi cos I said something
interesting he says that one of the
problems is when you actually meet real
anime fans in real life sometimes they
tend to be really shy in real life and
wallflowers whereas online they might be
outgoing but and I've noticed this I
think that you know when you go to anime
conventions or um stuff like that you do
notice a lot of people are actually shy
in real life they're not as outgoing as
there are on the Internet
I personally don't have that problem
because I'm always I'm not sure I'm
always kind of outgoing
I enjoy talking to people debating
people if I don't debate them about
animal debate them about politics or
history or something else right however
I do then notice that so any thoughts
that you guys might have on that issue
stay inside forever never go outside
don't make any friends and you'll never
have any bullies I don't think you
should stay inside in your freaking room
forever I mean I think it's pretty much
antisocial there's pretty much
antisocial you don't go out you need to
go out it's the same as social as it
gets there I'm sorry sir no no I'm
pretty sure none of us here is anti
chauffeur's anti-social we all go out we
all go we're all we're all youtubers I
feel like we have to be certainly guys
like outgoing to a certain extent right
so we're not the best examples but there
are a lot of shy anime fans without the
air and that is true they are right it's
it's hard to break people out of their
shell especially just did you're not
willing to I wouldn't overly try to but
it's accepted for who they are there are
a lot of outgoing anime fans as well
because it's such a big community like
you said there's some toxic fans try
fans outgoing fans it's gotta go online
find the right people go to conventions
but unfortunately guys I think I'm all
out of time I don't know I returned yeah
well actually we're about winding it
down I think as well so recon you can
say kind of who you are and what you do
before you head off cuz they getting
late at recons house and it is a week
that's correct and I do have caused more
so yeah sad times for everyone and
probably all of us have I have you know
school and stuff but anyways my name is
I'm a recon and I run the lead did he
just disappear nothing is left
I run the
recon bro it was a sad day when we lost
recon no pico rest in peace people cried
people died and people why is it raining
that rhyme rest in peace
yeah so that was weird recon but you
know we still love you bro hopefully
you're okay ouki says honestly though my
experience the best way to deal with any
bullies to just ignore them or don't let
them let or don't let whatever they say
get to you yeah that's a huge thing like
try not to let what um bullies if it's
just verbal kind of bullying just kind
of teasing don't let that get to you
because like I said the people were
bullies being bullies says more about
them than it does about you the fact
that they need to put someone down to
feel good about themselves or to impress
others means that there's something
wrong with them not you so don't take it
personally think of it as that's
actually a sign that they have problems
not you obviously if it's getting
physical and stuff like that then it is
a problem you have to address and get
some help
but yeah usually if someone's just
teasing you know stuff like that don't
get to you because if you let it get you
they win because that's what they're
trying to try to get a reaction out of
you yeah don't give them the
satisfaction of like getting that
reaction right had another viewpoint by
2spooky hmm remember life gets way way
easier as soon as you stop caring what
people think as then just do you and if
you just do you then the people who like
that are gonna come to you
lava traction baby do you man do you
know that was deep Mack thank you that's
what we have you on to see funny [ __ ]
and then once in a while one good thing
one Dzi once a while you get all Clannad
after story on us person I don't
understand
spoilers thankfully no one Kurt daudt
your ape so those are we I'm sorry
[Music]
break Briggs
any final thoughts on this topic in
terms of what you think I think we more
or less covered like most aspects of it
it's a tough situation yeah it's like I
said there's no like definitive answer
on this guy's because you have different
situations so you can have a community
where you know if you live in a bigger
place where anime is completely normal
you can have a community that's very
closed-minded you can have bully that's
just kind of like our own guy teases you
whatever gets bored leaves you can have
a bully that's incessant and obsessive
and violent right so there's different
situations and for different situations
you have to act in different ways but in
general I think that in terms of what
you can control definitely don't let it
get to you don't let these people affect
how you feel about yourself because um I
feel that yeah like if you do that they
win and you have to remember that them
acting this way it just shows that they
have issues with them it's not your
fault it's their fault so just think of
it that way if anything you should feel
sorry for someone who's a bully because
they have a lot of underlying issues
that they're trying to mask with their
bully persona so if you know if it's
just like teasing stuff like that don't
let it get to you get out of stay away
from those kind of people and then find
communities of people where you can that
actually support you that are supportive
and so forth hopefully you can find some
people in your family your other friends
maybe not for school but for somewhere
else work internet whatever there's so
many different people out there in the
world so with so many different
interests you're always gonna find
someone who agrees with you who has the
same interests so don't despair and
especially if you're in high school like
we all said recon said he just he's
recently out of high school and as he
said you know in high school it's hard
you have to deal with the same people
all the time and often you don't like
them but after that you have a lot more
independence and things get much better
so don't you know don't despair Mac tell
us what you are and what you are and who
you do I'm maginot and I make sarcastic
videos on the Internet
and I'm working on a few shenanigans
right now but they've been taking time
I've been super busy super super busy
but I'll be back regularly shortly but
yeah it's just a lot of a lot of skits a
lot of satire a lot of half-ass kind of
content good stuff so if you like that
come come check it dude come check it
out there's some cool cool new stuff
coming in the next few days I also
stream on Twitch but I haven't done that
in like three weeks so that's oh you're
having it yeah Ben wait wait wait wait
wait wait to do what are we some people
that try to be talk to me about whether
I should cut my hair I'm actually
growing it out so if you're rooting for
me to cut it
tough tough guys um what else was I
gonna say Tom in the chat was saying he
doesn't know if bullying is that much of
an issue and again it depends on on the
person because for me bullying is I
might really try not to deal with it
anymore I did a bit like I said but not
for anime I when I was younger but for
some people it is right and especially
they're still in high school and things
of that so it is a difficult situation
for some people for some people we you
know we don't deal with it every day we
have the confidence to not deal with it
but I think it's an important subject to
talk about regardless and kind of share
our experiences and help maybe you help
someone in a situation that's difficult
ah
is there something else there and by the
way uh links in the description for
Briggs for Mac and for recon no pico who
just disappeared
randomly um Briggs tell us who you are
and what you do and tell us how to work
out hard enough to be Jack like you so
then we don't have to get worried about
bullies ah first step watch my three
steps to become super saiyan video
that's way too old and pretty horrible
but uh yeah that's summer ice other oh
yeah great I recommend it I am Briggs
from the YouTube channel all day anime
and a fact videos where it's like it's
little thing cool stuff that you
wouldn't already know about characters
in series lately I've been doing a lot
of explained videos or like a
combination of the two I don't know my
content to come honestly but
it's explaining concepts about anime
like one for all all for one in my hero
academia explained in the 70s in school
stuff like that uh yeah that's about it
Luna don't worry you are officially a
member of the shim Paco lions any
bullies they guess they'll get locked up
you know actually you have been promoted
to a captain it's a highest honor the
highest honor oh I'm a captain too so
yes
yeah you're on par with adamak think
about that and of course Luna isn't this
for two guys and Briggs and Mac I would
like to see you more into discord cuz
you guys are great guys I know I know
you have a lot of stuff to do but if you
can drop by let me know I'll try to be
there at the same time we'll have a
little impromptu party cuz always like
seeing you guys there I am down my
noggin when you're doing that you gotta
say instance I wasn't my head sorry
sorry do I have to do it out loud oh
yeah please don't do it now do you maybe
right now
I'm just gonna leave bye yes again the
screen guys so that's my exit later v
one better have some clip of that making
a gift for something please that's
beautiful
even spiral says what's up hey even
spiral how's it going and red Yuma is in
here I I didn't shut him out before but
I've seen him a few times and yeah guys
so we're gonna call it a night now we
have some stuff to do I may or may not
be working on an anime inks to battle
rap you know
no spoilers maybe maybe not I just keep
I keep talking about it for some reason
I don't know why but you know you might
or might not have that looked forward to
look forward to it sometime in the
future thank you again for all the
support with the new videos and the
channel growing so quickly that is
amazing of course every one of you
regulars coming to rent cafe and
supporting us that's always such an
honor we love doing this we do this
every week 5 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
on 3rd
days just a fun place where a bunch of
anime youtubers get together talk to you
about anime talking with the chat all
that stuff so if you want to join us you
can come every Thursday 5 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time and yeah and the links
again to these lovely gentlemen their
channels are in the description and
until next time guys see a space cowboys
bang shin Paul kudu